denn die sache weil sie hier
jetzt muss auf jeden fall runter so hier
bin ich dann gelaufen ganz unterhalt
durch lava
ich denke mal sind jemand aber es ist
mal was anderes diese quellen sind nach
din oder wie das heißt
er bringt überhaupt das muss ich auf
jeden fall ein bisschen bayern
niemand hat fünf minuten zeit glaube ich
fünf minuten aber ich sagte ja bei mir
waren sie vorbei das war unschön
ich sehe schon wieder hoch ja toll jetzt
komme ich nicht weil ich keine sachen
habe toll
soll ich aber wenn ihr in deine richtung
gehen vergesse ich wo ich hier langen
wowi zurück müssen
ich weiß aber ich habe mein geld wert
sagte ich frei bin irgendwie sowas nähe
von dir eigentlich das will ich sehe ich
muss jetzt eigentlich genau nach unten
soll steckt unter dir als freiraum
erwarte ich laufe hier so einen kleinen
weg hierhin gekommen
ja aber sonst brauche ich es einfach
frei ihr bevor die sachen wechseln das
vitra scheiße ja dann bei einfach frei
nicht läuft gerade hin
okay sagt wo du willst ich gebe es nach
oben dass ich noch besser hier genau
hier kommt zu mir jetzt über mich wenn
du kannst kann ich nicht ich bin wartet
vielleicht also kannst es nicht mehr
bauen gerade scheiße ich bin jetzt
irgendwas ist stockfinster hier
tacke das nicht gut ich sehe relativ
wenig hier geht es doch mal hier geht's
hoch mein herz nicht abstieß gartens
gerät auch nicht auch ein bisschen auf
mich aufpassen
ich habe keinen plan wo ich bin du bist
23 meter von mir weg ja ich sehe diese
ist bleibt mal da bleibt man da wo du
bist was man gesammelt sachen eigentlich
gesagt naja ich bin ja voll ich bin ja
voll
ich sehe gar nichts sagt deshalb sind
die sachen ja durchweg deshalb meine ich
nur kann schnell kommt schnell
ich weiß nicht ich sehe ja nur dena ist
es alles schwarz sehen und du kannst
super nachricht du kannst nichts bauen
ich kann die kundin okay weil ich
brauche ich jetzt einfach schön zu dir
hier so schnell es geht
scheiße hast du fackeln gib mir
wenigstens fackeln oder so du bist
elfmeter von mir weg jetzt frei ja ich
kann mir schon gefreut 9
ich weiß nicht wo ich hin muss damit ich
am schnellsten
ich bin fast vier meter noch muss er
sofort gelaufen kommen wo ich sagen da
43 ich habe blog
wo ist da was ich mir hier
ich bin dann aufgestockt scheiße nochmal
deine sachen ein so alles geht aber ich
hab die meisten sachen sind ja ich bin
voll haltmachen kiste was euch
einsammelten anzunehmen sachen auf und
schmeißt dann wieder weg dann sind wir
wieder fünf minuten
ich bringe auf das wasser zu und sterbe
in der luft
welche tipps ich brauche am meisten
brauche ich anzüge die lava und
durchlässig sind aber david hat einfach
genau die gleiche todesursache wie
folien auch wieder gegen block
gesprungen in den lava diese fraktion
aber egal ich muss jetzt wieder dahin
und durch den komischen weggelaufen ist
das ärgerlich wo es auch noch gutes
fleisch
ich bin schon wieder nur 50 meter von
meinem latest weg ich habe ich
eigentlich alles hier einmal was ich
gefühlt noch ein bisschen verbrannt weil
es ziemlich nah an der laaber
ich komme gleich nochmal näher zu dir
hahaha jetzt habe ich nicht aber
geschickt aber hat irgendwas von dir
eingesammelt der zombie ich antrieb an
der stirn ich bin ja sofort wieder da
ich glaube ich bin dein weg auch wieder
okay führte irgend ein bisschen
falschangabe ich warte hier einfacher
lucys dieses jahres ja ich müsste jetzt
eigentlich näher kommt hat ich muss hier
das weiß ich noch hier so dann bin ich
hier
ja nämlich nicht irgendwie ich springe
auch gleich noch in die lava voll nicht
gut
ne na.de latest es ja ich sehe ich mich
wenn ich irgendwo unter wasser war noch
mal den weg den du mir gebaut hast
scheiße war immer schlecht
wo ist der name fällt ebenfalls
einnahmen voll gesehen ist er wieder weg
da ist auch dein name eigentlich ja ich
sehe dich komm rein gelaufen dann
geradeaus und zwar so dass gleich ein
klarer fall bestimmt nicht glück ab wow
du hast mir hier schon mal ein weg
gebaut das weiß ich habe ja keinen
packen dann sehe ich das fast da bleibt
man stehen wo du bist du bist doch was
bei der herrlich also hier ausleuchten
das ist echt gut ist weil diesmal nicht
in die lava nicht dein ernst ist extra
gemacht was ich nicht will muss einfach
mal ins gefängnis
jetzt sieht man nicht viel aber auch
durch ersteht creeper direktor bei ecke
hier unten musst du da durch mit dem
wasser und dann auf den weg den ich
gemacht habe
aber es fehlt alles
er ist alles weg es wurde voll wenig
hier gewesen
es war nicht so viel hast du denn eisen
spitzhacken teyssen zum beispiel eisen
habe ich aber meinen einem schwert habe
ich nicht wer ab sofort ein zeichen
werten ich hab nur ein eisen schwert
hier ehrlich das traurig ich hab gar
kein eisen und steals ressort das war ja
meint ja wie gesagt die sachen waren in
der lage ein bisschen was gestorben
wenn schon acht minuten
ja weil dann erst 45 minuten wir nehmen
schon die sieben seiten nun auf mensch
sollten langsamer wahrscheinlich nach
hause zurückkehren
das hat sich für mich jetzt aber kein
bisschen gelohnt fast alle sachen ich
habe vier eisen das war es kommt hier
noch mal ein bisschen reisen
und hier noch ein bisschen kuba zu den
sachen von mir eingesammelt ich habe es
nur eine sammlung sie sofort wieder raus
zu werfen damit die fünf minuten
verdoppelt werden
eine schaufel ja aber das war ich hatte
mir selbst zu haben
ich hasse diese hülle
ich würde sagen wir suchen natürlich
eine andere auf jeden fall raus
ich muss erst warten bis ich mein leben
wieder wissen voller ist durch junge
mensch hast du denn diamanten
ich hab ja ich hab noch nie diamanten
bekommen ein trost der mann mit dem ein
kannst nix machen jena mit einem kann
ich mir schon bald machen was kannst du
mir schaufel bringt ja auch nichts mit
neuen kann allerdings schon
es gibt ja irgendwelche guten sachen die
man damit machen kann ich muss erstmal
checken was man damit machen kann ja
nein vielleicht später wenigstens wenn
ich sehe okay das und das machen dann
kannst du noch das und das machen und
dann habe ich viel eisen geschenk und
kopper
bitte 1 außen vorbei ich will dass du
nach hause kommst du mit kommst du mit
der kritik nicht lagen ist nach hause
unter mir gesehen vielleicht einen
anderen weg suchen ja dollar hoch ich
bin einfach schnell hoch und hoffen dass
kein nächsten nichts mehr kommt welche
weißer farbe so eingesprungen um den
hier ich werde mal aus das update ist
noch immer dass auch er unter der ist
kein problem einfach dahinter die
hobelspäne rüber und hoch hinter die
hoch hinter dir überspringt hochging
dass ich möchte auch ein bisschen ertrag
weniger sie mitnehmen
jasmin ist glaube ich gar nicht so
wichtig aber es sieht alles aus wie
diamanten ja einfach er genau und
deswegen sage ich auch alles ein und
dann verliere ich doch wieder alles zum
beispiel was ist das blaue hier das
kenne ich gar nicht was hast du da bist
fortan ihr blaues haus ich muss jetzt
nach hause sonst sonst sonst weiß ich
dass das schief läuft
es läuft nämlich immer noch ein bisschen
länger hier bleiben
es war das hast du dir helfen oder
schaffte das schaffe ich aber mainspitze
kaputt geht noch weiter aber wir müssen
aber hier hoch weiß draußen wo sich
natürlich bewusst dass es mir lange
mussten da war ich weil ich dich hier
drei wahl geholt ja gut zweimal
es hat sich angefühlt wie dreimal über
treiber nicht die perser anwender opec
doch cool grüne hier gucken wir mal
nächst grüner saphir rubin verschiedene
sachen ein buntes allerlei so ok dann
glaube ich ja ich gehe hoch also ich
sehe
hast du jetzt die stadt eingespeichert
208 kw sind falsch nicht hoch aber wir
sind es schon voll auf der hohen höhe
weil wir uns hier raus bauen ja gleich
stark dafür
wir sind 157 ich habe keine fackeln wird
einfach eine fackel hey leute vorher
nicht einfach mal nach oben bist du
hinter mir ich wollte dir müssen lied
singen damit wir diese totenstille
überbrücken
lagerfeuer holzmichl noch wir sind
hackl außen also bisher zurück gelaufen
weil sie auch nicht voll angst vor dir
und sowas mit geschlagen werden so war
richtig und bleibt erstmal weg gott
nicht immer wieder selber orangene
steine ja du musst du abbauen
aber ich gehört fackel bei euch einfach
mal trägt jetzt nach oben eher hoch hoch
hoch hoch springen so was nein ich bin
doch schon hier beim ja das ist schon
wieder doch ok abzustatten auch wenn
jetzt irgendwelche monster sind kanye
uns wirklich eine rüstung
ja ich möchte ich möchte action action
das spinnen weg versucht ihr zu helfen
der komische nach der ist das denn das
seien artverwandt trotzdem nicht
schlagen es tot kannibale schnappte
hundezone alter ich gleich so ja da
hätten statt sich in diese grüne
fontaine ja auch das ist unser wasser
straße gegangen
ich bin ins gewicht dass sofort ein
vertrag geschlossen mit dem ich habe
zwei herzen
gemeinschafts fällt mit weizen alles
leer
das soll hier wahrscheinlich entstehen
hat jemand ne coole idee wo ist das
weizen ja gut wenn wir jetzt sagen das
war's für die ersten drei folgen bei mir
bei dem was jetzt eine folge
ich muss man gucken wie ich das so
machen guck mal wie ihr könnt auf folie
aus sicht von crafter könnt ihr einen
blick ist in der beschreibung
dass die anderen so machen link zu jedem
teilnehmer ist auch in der beschreibung
das megaprojekt und weiter geht es
demnächst genau
vielen dank fürs duschen hat ein
bisschen macho